today on the matt well show with war
raging in europe our leaders here at
home are focused on the important things
namely outlawing lynching but isn't that
already illegal and why does it need to
be illegal again and why are they
worried about that why now of all times
we'll sort we'll sort through all that
today also there's so much propaganda
flying around about the war in ukraine
that it could be hard to keep things
straight or to know exactly what's going
on it's probably no surprise though that
the people pushing the propaganda are
also the people who want to push our
country into a direct armed conflict
with russia we'll discuss and democrats
try and fail to pass a federal law
permanently in shrining row regardless
of the supreme court's decision plus
kamala harris goes off script joe biden
can barely walk and john oliver makes
the case for decriminalizing
prostitution across the country i'll
explain why he's wrong and also why he's
canceled all of that and more today on
the matt wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know a common question i get from my
listeners is what can i do to help turn
the tide on the culture award the answer
is a simple one know your ideals and
fight for them one of the truths that
i'm constantly talking about is the
truth that life begins upon conception a
fact that the left is actively trying to
erase we have to fight tooth and nail to
defend the lives of these babies and if
you want to join this fight here is one
way to do it by disconnecting your
current phone service provider who
doesn't care about the life of the
children and lives of children in fact
is probably very much against you when
it comes to that issue and every other
issue and switch instead to charity
mobile a phone service that does care
about life charity mobile will donate
five percent of your monthly plan price
to pro-life charities of your choice all
while giving you access to the latest 5g
phones with great nationwide coverage if
this sounds like a hassle i assure you
it isn't charity mobile
makes switching from their current
carrier pain list their live customer
service is exceptional and they'll guide
you through the process you can keep
your number and phone or if you want you
can even take advantage of my special
offer and get a free cell phone with
free activation all you have to do is
call 1-877-474
or chat with them online at
charitymobile.com and mention offer code
walsh to redeem your free phone and free
activation that's charitymobile.com and
mention offer code walsh join the fight
for the life of of children by switching
to charity mobile today
well these are volatile times dangerous
times war has already broken out in
eastern europe if the crisis is not
handled with prudence and resolve and
restraint and foresight the conflict
could well spread across the globes
sending us barreling headfirst into
another world war
this is a time for competent assured
intelligent leadership it's unfortunate
then that the western world is led by
the most pathetic collection of morally
bankrupt half-wits our civilization has
ever seen
these are the people we must entrust to
to guide us through this calamity
without getting 50 million people killed
in the process frankly i don't love the
odds right now
and i'm not feeling any better today
considering what happened in dc last
night
with the world teetering on the brink of
nuclear destruction congress which can
never be accused of having its
priorities straight got together to work
on making lynching illegal
yes that violent act which literally
hasn't occurred one single time in this
country in at least 40 years
that's the thing they decided to focus
on they might as well pass a law
prohibiting the use of giant catapults
to storm fortresses
maybe next they can finally legally ban
people from burning witches at the stake
how about a law once again um abolishing
the transatlantic slave trade
now i'm not being totally fair they
didn't just work on outlawing lynching
they also tried to do some other things
like they uh they tried to pass a bill
banning something called hair
discrimination
that's hair discrimination
it's called the creating a respectful
and open world for natural hair or crown
act
and it would make it illegal to
discriminate against hairstyles worn by
black people now you might be thinking
that
discrimination against black people is
already illegal and it is
but this bill would make a black
person's hairstyle its own protected
class
so black people would be protected from
discrimination twice over once for their
whole body and then a second time for
the top of their heads
eventually i'm sure democrats will pass
laws specifically protecting each
marginalized body part individually
so we've covered head discrimination
what about shoulder discrimination what
about knees and toes and eyes and ears
and mouth and nose head shoulders knees
and toes knees and toes
you can tell i have a two-year-old at
home sorry about that but the dreadlock
protection act of 2022 uh didn't pass uh
that was one bit of empty virtue
signaling that republicans refused to go
along with
the same cannot be said for the
anti-lynching act however
which was an even more dangerous and
grotesque form of virtue signaling but
as for that republicans were fully on
board save for three there were three
republicans who rightfully voted against
the measure including thomas uh massey
from kentucky who's you know one of the
only good ones left
but they were not enough to prevent this
bill from passing and so the the emmett
till anti-lynching act was passed with
near near unanimous support from both
parties and the bill now makes it a
federal hate crime
to lynch somebody or to conspire to
lynch somebody
now before the bill's passage various
members of congress took turns you know
standing on the floor of congress
bravely denouncing this despicable act
which was already illegal
and which doesn't happen anymore at all
to anybody
squad member cory bush of course made
sure to get her time in the spotlight
listen to her
those who survived the middle passage
survived only to be brought onto these
shores bought and sold at auctions like
the goods their forced labor was
producing
these auctions launched a long-standing
practice in america in which white folks
including white women
scrutinize and violate the bodies of
black people especially black women
we're going to tell the truth today
black adults and black children enslaved
and forced to endure being tormented
being tortured being raped by white
slave owners on owners on slave ships
and on the plantations
our ancestors
tried to escape the bondage of slavery
just to be hunted
captured imprisoned
executed
executed
why is she uh talking about this why is
she talking about slavery and why does
she pretend that in denouncing slavery
she's bravely telling a truth that
nobody else will say out loud
well we're going to tell the truth today
oh how brave about slavery
i was joking before about the democrats
outlawing slavery all over again
maybe that's really where this is headed
and i guess i can see why the democrats
were all in favor of slavery the first
time around so it's only fair to give
them a chance to you know get on the
right side of the issue but as for the
anti-lynching act
two points must be emphasized
one as discussed
nobody is getting lynched in modern
america thank god
the last case was in
1981 five years before i was born
and that was an extraordinary event
because it was the first such occurrence
in decades
so since my parents were born you could
count the number of lynchings on maybe
like one hand and you may not need all
your
fingers since i was born it hasn't
happened at all
not once
anywhere in the country
now does that mean that it should be
legal well of course not
and the good news is that it's not legal
it's always been illegal if you lynch a
person today with or without this bill
you will go to prison for a very long
time
though ironically with this bill you may
actually go to prison for a shorter
length of time than you otherwise would
have
because the legislation prescribes a
sentence of not more than 30 years now i
would have thought that lynching should
carry a life sentence or a death
sentence but you know that's just me
i guess i'm tougher on lynching than
than the democrats are
in fact lynching isn't just already
illegal
race-based lynching
lynchings committed for racist reasons
are illegal twice over
okay because lynching is murder or
attempted murder which is illegal
if it's racially motivated then it's
race-based violence which is already a
hate crime
so no black people are getting lynched
in america but if such a horrific event
did occur
it would already be illegal twice
illegal on the state and the federal
level
illegal and then illegal again
so this law makes it illegal a third
time
why stop there let's make it illegal
four times
let's make it illegal every year by 2030
we should have over 10 laws outlawing a
crime that nobody is committing anyway
by the way this is true even if you
expand the definition of lynching to
include things that are not lynching
which is what the left has done in order
to make the case that lynching is still
a problem in the united states what
they'll always do is they'll they'll say
well george floyd was a lynching victim
or a mod arbory
but words have meanings
and those don't apply
if if lynching now just means any
violence committed against a black man
by a white man for allegedly racist
reasons well again
that's already illegal
the wikipedia article lynching in the
united states actually lists a mod
arbory as a victim if you go to
wikipedia and you trust them as a source
they have a list of all the victims of
lynching and they have
according to them there's been one case
of lynching
in uh in the 21st century and a mod
arbory was the victim
except that he was not lynched and
anyway
his killers have already been convicted
of murder and a hate crime
so even under the expanded definition of
lynching
in fact especially under the expanded
definition there's no need for this law
it already exists
so what is the point
i mean why are they doing this
well the primary point obviously is to
virtue signal
treating the law itself like at some
kind of twitter hashtag
now all of these lawmakers can appear in
campaign videos declaring that they
bravely took a stand and finally once
and for all banned this terrible
practice
they'll just hope that their
constituents are too stupid to realize
that it was already banned and also that
they were wasting time on this empty
stunt
while the world stood at the precipice
of nuclear annihilation but there's
something else too
and this is what makes this
more than an empty stunt and more than
just a silly and pointless symbolic
gesture but something far more sinister
as well this is also why spineless
republicans should have refused to go
along with the charade but they didn't
refuse because they're well spineless
and that is this the law is meant to
send a message
that lynching is still a current and
urgent problem in the united states
that's that's that's what this is it's
psychological conditioning
it's kind of like you know if you stand
in a crowd and you look up at the sky
inquisitively everybody else will look
up too they'll assume that because
you're looking up there there must be
something there
and so when congress passes a law
banning lynching for the third time um
stupid people will assume that okay well
if they had to pass a law banning
lynching then i guess it still happens
so this is all part of the overarching
effort to paint our country as
systemically racist against minorities
which it is not
it is a narrative booster most of all
and that's what our leaders are
concerned with at a time like this
because they're not leaders
we have no leaders in this country
only parasites and con artists playing
the part
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
are you having trouble finding good meat
to buy at the store you know when my
wife goes grocery shopping for the
household because she always goes she
doesn't trust me to do it she comes home
to tell me horror stories about the
nearly empty shelves and the only
options that remain are unappealing and
cheap cuts of meat well good thing we
don't rely on the grocery store for our
meat thanks to good ranchers we are
eating well every single night good
ranchers is a meat delivery service that
delivers prime american grown cuts
directly to your door they offer
everything from steaks burgers chicken
and even seafood the best part getting
this delicious meat painlessly delivered
actually saves money and gives you
better quality than the cheap cuts you
find at store
good ranchers also offers a subscription
service so you can schedule how often
you want their boxes delivered and
you'll save even more than purchasing
just one box now thanks to me my family
eats premium meat every night i guess i
can give my wife some credit too now
i'll give myself all the credit for that
so be like my family and eat well every
night without breaking the bank by
visiting goodranchers.com walsh and just
to spice this offer up some more if you
uh use my code wall should check out you
can get an additional thirty dollars off
your first order that's goodranchers.com
walsh get to get 30 off your first order
of great american meat from good
ranchers
all right sorry i missed the show
yesterday i'm a deadbeat i actually had
to call out sick if you can believe it
first time i i think the first time i've
ever done that that i can remember
and it was worse because i didn't really
call out i was already here in the
building and i got to the office even
earlier than usual so you know and i was
working on my show and i was doing show
prep
and i started to feel a little bit off
and
i began to rapidly deteriorate
and i end up getting hit hard with it
with a stomach bug and i'll spare you
the details unless you really want them
but i assume you don't so i had to go to
my boss's office and like ask to go home
it was pretty humiliating and i'm just
i'm humiliated to be sick like some kind
of mere mortal
and i haven't then i was thinking about
i don't think i've had to do anything
like that since grade school
that's the last time i called out sick
for something but back then i was almost
always making it up so that's the big
difference
so here i you know i went home and um
i was just i was in bed like all day and
my wife got me popsicles and crackers
and gatorade
and it was kind of nice to be honest i
remembered why i enjoyed being sick back
in uh back in high school so much it's
more enjoyable when you're not really
sick and you're pretending but um it
still was kind of nice and i was
thinking i might start cashing this chip
in more often who knows because
sometimes people can
have stomach bugs that flare up on a
semi-regular basis say like twice a
month or something you know what happens
a lot of times it'll hit on a friday
really really weird sort of like
scientific phenomenon
and uh so you never know what might
happen
all right let's um
i want to start with this
it's from the daily wire it says
prominent anti-trump republican
representative adam kinzinger fell for
an infamous hoax last week tweeting
support for comedian sam hyde whom
kinzinder apparently believed to be the
so-called ghost of kiev due to a poorly
photoshopped tweet
kinses are captured in a now deleted
tweet
the ghost to kiev has a name and has
absolutely owned the russian air force
god speed and more kills
samuel
fans of hydes are known for trying to
dupe journalists and others by falsely
claiming hide as the culprit or hero in
various events and memes supporters
often reply or caption the hoax posts
saying something like he can't keep
getting away with this so this is what
um adam king was doing
and look
the truth is that there's been a ton of
propaganda
lies otherwise known um flying around
you know par pardon the pun um in this
case with with the ghost of kia there
was even a video which turned out to be
a video from a video game which uh
supposedly showed this ghost of kiev but
the volume of propaganda and the speed
with which it is disseminated is unlike
um
anything i i think i've i've seen
and this stuff matters and it matters
especially when guys like kinzinger are
propping up the narrative
so i mean the ghost of kiev was fake
um they also told us about the heroes of
snake island who chose death rather than
surrender to the russians
and i almost
i almost said i i on friday i heard
about that story right right before the
show on friday
and my first reaction was i don't know
if i believe this
and i almost said it on the show i
stopped myself from saying it because in
case i'm wrong you know it's it's uh i
didn't want to be the guy that was
doubting the um
the people who courageously gave their
lives and that that's one of the reasons
why this propaganda spread so rapidly
because you know you don't want to be
the one especially if you don't have any
evidence that it's false and when it
comes to this stuff
we're all
none of us are there so we can only we
just get this information and uh we
can't know if something's true or false
until other information comes along
but um you know that was the story about
the the heroes of snake island who um
i think there was supposedly 13
ukrainians who
told a russian warship to go after
themselves and then died heroically
rather than surrender well it turns out
that um they did indeed surrender and
are currently you know alive and doing
fine physically
um they told us about a russian tank
that chased down a ukrainian civilian
vehicle and crushed it there was video
of that
but now it seems that the tank was
actually ukrainian
and when you watch that video again you
see the video and you see the tank and
you say well
do we know that's a russian tank
and the video is oddly cropped too
because it it anytime you see like an
eight-second video
that carefully cuts off everything that
happened before and after that should
send up some red flags and that was the
case there
um there have been pictures floating
around of ukrainian president zielenski
and body armor on the battlefield that
were actually taken months ago
other pictures of ukrainian supermodels
charging to the front lines holding what
turned out to be airsoft rifles
i mean there's this whole narrative
about about basically supermodels who
are charging to the front lines and
shooting the bad guys
and um
i mean maybe that's happening i'm not
there
it sounds suspiciously cinematic and
like something hollywood would come up
with
and a lot of the videos turn out to be
fake and a lot of the photographs too
there was a viral video of a ukrainian
girl
standing up to a russian soldier and
berating him and saying you know get out
of the country well you can't really
tell what you're saying because it's in
a foreign language that's the other
problem there's a there's a
a language barrier here
the problem with that video is that uh
it was obviously taken in the desert in
summertime the little girl's wearing
like a tank top
and uh it's winter time in ukraine right
now and there's snow everywhere
so these are all lies and there are many
others along with you know a whole
collection of dramatic and suspicious
stories that haven't yet been totally
debunked but um but haven't been proven
either
like the story that russian
russia sent mobile crematoriums onto the
battlefield to burn their dead bodies
and hide their losses
i mean
that has not been confirmed but that was
another story that was spread everybody
was spreading it
sends up a red flag for me
i don't know
speaking of the of russia's losses
ukraine says it's killed almost 5 000
russian troops in a few days
nearly doubling the number of americans
killed in afghanistan in 20 years
seems like an extraordinary figure
um maybe it's true i you know i don't
know
and if it is true you'd think we'd have
seen video by now of battlefields
littered with dead bodies we haven't
really
seen that
maybe that's because they're taking the
bodies and throwing them into the mobile
crematorium i mean that's the narrative
anyway
it sounds extraordinary i mean it's
extraordinary 5 000 i mean it's
extraordinary 5 000 killed in action in
less than a week
being covered up by by this battalion of
of of mobile crematoriums it's a that's
an extraordinary thing doesn't mean it
didn't happen doesn't mean it's not
happening right now but it is
extraordinary and that's why you need
more evidence before you believe it
so um
and and this is the problem that to to
know what's happening in ukraine
we have to rely on some collection of
foreign governments
our government and the media
now as it happens i trust no one and
nothing less than i trust foreign
governments our government and the media
they have all earned my distrust and
yours
and then you add on top of that just the
general fog of war that you always have
and the fact that ukraine
you know we're getting all this
information from ukraine
and they have a reason to put propaganda
out it's actually it's a smart strategy
for them
propaganda is part of waging any war
especially in the internet age the
information age
and they they're certainly they're
winning the propaganda battle at least
in the west by a large margin
so i understand why they do it it makes
a lot of sense
i would do it too
if i was a
you know
ukrainian in charge of these things
but for those of us who care about the
truth we still want to know what's
actually happening
and this really matters okay
because i know when we when we um we
talk about this and those of us who have
pointed out that uh some of this stuff
it's really not true there's actually
not just some stuff a lot of stuff we're
being told that just isn't true and then
other stuff that sounds like it
the very good chance it's not true
although we just don't know
and anytime um
any of us say that we're always shouted
down and we're told that oh just let it
it's it's it's for morale
they understand morale for the ukrainian
troops but we're not ukrainian troops
if you want to go fight for ukraine by
the way zielinski has has sent the offer
up and said anyone is welcome to come
will give you a gun so you know anyone
in this country
really um feels strongly about it can
can go do that but
um most of us we're not ukrainian troops
so do do we need propaganda for our
morale what does that mean
and there's something
more insidious happening because guys
like adam kinzinger right
they're the ones in america who are
amplifying this propaganda
and adam kinzinger also insists as he
insisted last week that the fate of the
west
depends on the us establishing a no-fly
zone over ukraine which would be an act
of war against russia
okay
and others have echoed this call
yesterday richard engel one of the nbc's
one of nbc's most prominent
correspondents floated the idea that the
u.s should go in and bomb russian
convoys heading into ukraine
another act of war that would suck us
into a potentially cataclysmic
confrontation with a nuclear superpower
and of course there's a there's a
contradiction here because kinzinger
along with um
advocating for things that would get us
involved in a world war and saying that
the fate of the west depends on us
getting involved and you know shutting
down the airspace and fighting the
russians
he says that on one hand
but then on the other hand he's gloating
that russia is a paper tiger and they're
easily getting their butts whooped
well okay i mean i could buy the the
latter narrative but if that's the tr if
that's true then how does the fate of
the west depend on us getting involved
it's according to you they're a paper
tiger ukraine's doing a good job
handling them
how can these both be true
how can they be a paper tiger and the
fate of the west the very fate of our
civilization depends on us getting
involved
makes no sense
um all we know is that war is good for
the media business
it's also good for the neocon business
and so it's no surprise to see guys like
kinsenger pushing this stuff
you know there are people in our country
this again is why it matters to call it
the propaganda and to want to know the
truth that's all we're asking for just
tell me what's really going on that's
all i want to know
that's it
it's really important because there are
people in this country who want to get
us involved in a world war that's what
they want
that's why it disturbs me you know
senator rob portman a republican he was
on meet the press on sunday and he said
that um
and i've heard this before that you know
he said that people are more united now
um around ukraine than they've been in
our country since 9 11. you know he said
this is just like right after 9 11
people are very united
well
the unity i hate to be the the guy
peeing in the punch bowl here but the
unity after 9 11
was used to propel us into two decades
of disastrous and pointless wars
overseas
so and there are those who wish to
repeat that performance
but you can't question it
or contradict the narrative or dump on
the pro-war parade because if you do
you're you're a you're a stooge of putin
and this has been the message a message
that um hillary clinton among others has
been um
has been spreading she was on cable news
yesterday she was on msnbc
and she was there excoriating the
fictional pro-putin demographic in our
country let's listen to that
we have to also make sure that within
our own country
we are calling out those people
who are giving aid and comfort to
vladimir putin who are talking about
what a genius he is what a smart move it
is
who are unfortunately
being broadcast by russian media
not only inside russia but in europe to
demonstrate the division within our own
country
um so it's uh it's
people giving aid and comfort to putin
meanwhile mitt romney was on cable news
as well and uh he said that
those who
uh you know he's also going after this
alleged pro-putin
group
of republicans and he said that they're
uh they are actually treasonous they're
committing treason let's or or rather he
says they're they're nearly treasonous
they're they're almost very close to
treason let's listen
no place and and either political party
uh for this white nationalism or racism
it's simply wrong uh it's it's uh as as
you've indicated speaking of evil uh
it's evil as well and uh and you know
marjorie taylor greene and paul gosar i
don't know them but i'm reminded of that
old line from the butch cassidy the
sundance kid movie where where one
character says morons i've got morons on
my team and i have to think anybody that
would sit down with white nationalists
and speak at their conference was
certainly missing a few i keep iq points
and just more broadly the pro-putin
sentiment that you are seeing from some
corners of your party
well a lot of those people are are
changing their stripes as they're seeing
uh the the response of the world and the
political response here in the u.s but
how anybody
how anybody in this country
which loves freedom
can side with vladimir putin
which is an oppressor a dictator he
kills people
he he imprisons that's that's good yeah
that's a good question i mean how could
anybody in this country side with
vladimir putin
yep i have the same question because
nobody is doing that
nobody of no
nobody nobody prominent
with vladimir putin aid and comfort to
putin who's doing that what does that
even mean by the way
i wouldn't know how to give aid and
comfort to a foreign dictator even if i
wanted to what would i do send them a
care package
maybe a gift basket from pro flowers how
does that work exactly
well i can speak i can speak for myself
um
and this is something i i shouldn't need
to say out loud
but um no i don't support putin nor do i
wish to give him aiden comfort i don't i
don't first of all support any foreign
leader i don't even support most of our
own leaders i especially don't support
putin who's an anti-american dictator so
it's not a tough call for me
he's also the aggressor in this
situation invading a foreign country i'm
always going to side
um
most of the time anyway it's a pretty
easy call to side with the people who
are defending their homeland who are
being invaded
and when the person doing the invasion
is an anti-american dictator well again
easy call
but i also don't like being lied to
and right now we're being lied to by
lots of people about a lot of things
and i don't like that
um this is also why the outbreak of
virtue signaling is is not only
you know annoying but troubling all the
people who are you know it's one thing
people put the ukrainian flag in their
in their twitter bio or whatever i mean
personally i i am not going to march
under even symbolically even even
virtually any flag under other than the
united states flags i'm not putting any
i'm not putting any foreign flag in my
bio people are doing that they're you
know hashtag stand with ukraine they're
changing their profile pics all that
kind of stuff
okay i mean it's it's it it's it's an
empty gesture whatever but then then we
move on people are dumping their russian
vodka down the sink
that you already bought
okay
and they're even governors who are
outlawing russian vodka
even though you know much of the vodka
in the united states actually isn't from
russia
it's already been purchased
and anyway we're still importing 20
million barrels of russian oil per month
so that that's i think the perfect
picture of empty virtue signaling is
we're going to dump the russian vodka
down the sink and take our russian
nesting dolls and waterboard them and
toss them in the ocean maybe burn our
tolstoy you know russian literature
if you have any russian dressing in the
in the fridge go throw that up while
we're still importing
20 million barrels six hundred thousand
barrels i think it is a day
of russian oil
you want to hurt russia you stopped
doing that but we're not going to stop
doing that
but all the virts you're saying people
get caught up in this fervor and they
start dumping their vodka and doing all
this stuff which by the way i mean go
ahead and dump the vodka anyway because
it's disgusting but people doing this it
just shows how easily manipulated they
are
and then i worry
that
if next thing you know
we're marching into a world war
um
there are a lot of people are going to
march lockstep along with it
so that's my concern
all right so from the um
from the national review here's some
good news
says this this evening the senate failed
failed to proceed to a vote on the
women's health protection act a radical
piece of pro-abortion legislation
that co-device codifies roe versus wade
establishing a fundamental right to
abortion on demand and nullify state
pro-life laws across the country it was
a 46 to 48 vote with six senators not
voting
the bill which passed the house last
fall with the support of every democrat
but one is now effectively dead far from
achieving these 60 votes needed to
proceed to vote it didn't even achieve
50 votes so
i think i sold them short a little bit
not only were democrats
last night spending their time trying to
outlaw lynching and outlaw hair
discrimination whatever the hell that is
they were also fighting for the right to
continue murder murdering babies no
matter what the supreme court says
and lots of uh democrats got up
on the floor of the senate and
you know spoke out in favor of killing
babies including chuck schumer let's
listen to what he had to say
across the country
it is a dark dark time for women's
reproductive rights
last year we saw the most the most
abortion restrictions
passed by state legislatures in a single
year
some of them were almost vicious the
vigilantism of texas's law i called
vicious vigilantism
many of these new laws are downright
extreme
effectively extinguishing women's
ability to even exercise their rights at
all
and
the new extreme restrictions fly largely
in the face of public opinion
they also fly in the face of common
health
common sense health practices and
frankly they fly against common decency
itself
and sadly it seems like the supreme
court is close to drastically
restricting this long established right
in the coming months so there's uh
there's structure humor you know
speaking of valiantly for the right to
kill babies because that's what i mean
think about
with war happening in the world
and again the possibility especially
with the incompetent people running the
country that we could get involved in a
world war
this their their bloodlust is not
satisfied
what they're thinking about is how can
we make sure more people die
they're they're very concerned that in
the near future depending on the supreme
court decides
even though if the supreme court decides
to strike down roe v wade
um it will not mean unfortunately that
abortion is illegal now automatically
across the entire country
it will still be legal in many of the
most populated
cities and states it just goes back to
the states to decide but they're worried
that um in the near future
fewer babies will be killed they're very
concerned about that and they want to do
what they can to make sure codifying
this into
supersede
law
supreme court and make sure that babies
can still be killed all across the
country that's what they're concerned
about
with the women's health protection act
which i also don't have to point out but
i will
they're talking about the women's health
protection act but they can't tell you
what a woman is
that should be the the first thing
that you do
maybe this should be a law and if i were
in charge this would be a law
that you cannot pass a law
with woman or women's in the the title
unless you begin
in the language of the bill the very
first thing that you do should be to
define what the word woman is
i mean if you're going to make a law
about women's health then i think to
begin with
we're all going to have the really
logical question which is well what is
that exactly who are you talking about
whose health
i don't know what you mean
so you should have to start by defining
women which of course they can
all right so moving on camilla harris um
is really bad when she stays on script
even worse when she goes off script and
so this is a moment here it will play
for you i haven't seen this yet
if you haven't seen it yet you'll you'll
see it now then you're gonna you're
gonna see and hear it many more times
after this because this is going to
appear
in every gop campaign ad for the next
three years at least
um here is camilla harris yesterday
going off script
because as we all know elections matter
and when folks vote they order what they
want and in this case they got what they
asked for
i went off script a little bit
first of all what is that accent that
she does
uh second
yeah i mean i actually agree it's i
couldn't agree more
that you got what you asked for
that is going to be their campaign
slogan for reelection hey america you
got what you asked for
that's true at least at least a lot of
people you know we didn't all ask for it
but a lot of people did and that this is
exactly what they're getting
and when it comes to what they ask for
they also asked for joe biden who is a
man who is you know falling apart
physically and mentally in in every
other way
and we're at the point now with biden
now i've said before that i i would
prefer for him not to appear on camera
for him not to take questions for him
not to uh you know do any more press
conferences because i think it's become
almost a national security issue
the more that we advertise to the world
that hey look this is the dude who's in
charge over here the more that we do
that the more likely it is that we're
going to have
you know
we're going to end up in some kind of
world war
but it's so bad now that even when biden
even if he's not
saying anything and he's just walking he
somehow manages to embarrass himself
even in that context
so here he is walking
across the lawn of the white house
yesterday
and um
he's got his mask on let's go ahead and
play this
he's got he's got the mask on first of
all let's strike one
all by himself
outside with the mask on
but look how he's walking
you could tell that he's just focused
and this is a this is a nicely manicured
lawn it's not like he's walking through
mud or quicksand or anything like that
or even high even tall grass
you can tell he's you can you can almost
see the thought bubble
in his head he's thinking okay left foot
right foot left foot right foot
he's just terrified that he's going to
fall
he's already done that once
he looks like he's getting a field
sobriety test but he's had a few
and you know he's like he gets pulled
over and he's had a few the cop can
smell the alcohol in his breath and he
knows he's going to be when it comes
time to
you know to do the blood alcohol content
it's it's he's gonna it's gonna be close
and so he's ha the cops have him walk on
a line and you could just tell he's
doing everything he can to fool the
officer appear as sober as possible but
the harder he tries the more drunk he
appears
um that's what's happening in our
country that's that's the state that
we're in
uh again you gotta feel real good about
having these people especially those two
they're gonna be in charge of uh
navigating this crisis that we find
ourselves in all right i want to play
this for you uh quickly here's a local
news report about an assistant principal
in michigan who was arrested
for child sex abuse
and um
against system principle arrested for
child sex abuse
it even gets worse than that when you
hear about who the victim is
and where do you think this guy is right
now
let's watch and find out
assistant principal at e-course high
school facing criminal sexual conduct
charges involving a child 45 year old
melvin conway was arrested this morning
and arraigned this afternoon on one
count of first degree criminal sexual
conduct greg herms is live tonight
so grant what did the judge decide on
bond here
well the bond is relatively low just 75
000 he'll also have to be confined to
home arrest and wear a gps tracker that
will let him go back to work at the
school
[Music]
in court today e-course high school
assistant principal melvin conway the
45-year-old arrested by detroit police
and the wayne county sheriff's office a
sheriff's office spokesperson telling
local 4 conway is accused of sexual
misconduct in the case involving his
daughter and that the alleged incident
appeared to happen eight years ago
according to the wayne county
prosecutor's office the girl was just 10
years old at the time of the incident
and reported it last spring we see this
quite often
it looks like at some point
the victim
shared this information with someone
else who
took of the initiative to report the
incident the judge today said in
conway's bond at 75 000 along with house
arrest with a gps monitor so he can
still go to work at the school as of
this afternoon conway was still listed
as employed by the district local ford
asked for a comment today but did not
get one back conway is charged with
criminal sexual conduct
can still go work at the school arrested
for
quote-unquote sexual misconduct
with his daughter who's 10 years old and
he can still go work at school after
that
i've
been saying for years i'll keep saying
until
until i'm not the only one saying it
anymore
um
this is an epidemic in the school system
okay that right there is just one case
but it's in the context of an overall
epidemic that's been going on for years
uh there is an epidemic of sexual abuse
within the schools
now as far as we know this is not this
this uh crime did not occur in the
school itself
but the epidemic is sexual uh sex crimes
happening in the school and also sex
criminals being hired by schools and
allowed to stay there
even after their crimes are known
we're seeing the same thing in the
school system that we've seen so many
other institutions including the
catholic church where um uh you know
some something happens things are
reported and then you take that person
you just move into a different school
we've seen that too
this is this is an actual epidemic
and our government has known about it
i've told you before about the
the department of education actually did
a study about sexual misconduct by
teachers in schools they did this back
in 2004
and they found that it's it's it's
thousands and thousands of cases
it's very common
that was back in 2004 you think it's
gotten better since then
i guarantee it hasn't
because a problem like this if you don't
address it if you don't do anything
about it
it it certainly isn't going to go away
it's only going to get
worse it's like any any any other you
know you've got some putrid
uh disgusting mess and you sweep it
under a rug
it's just gonna fester under there and
get worse it's not gonna get better
and on top of that that's just the
natural course of these sorts of things
but on top of that
the the schools themselves
have becoming an increasingly sexual
environment
we're putting teachers more and more in
charge of having
uh radically inappropriate sexual
conversations with kids at very young
ages
and that is only going to encourage more
and more of these kinds of people
of predators
to
flock to these jobs
i mean one of these days eventually one
of these days we're actually all going
to start talking about this epidemic of
sexual assault and sexual abuse in the
school system uh but so far very few
people seem to care that much about it
which i cannot understand
uh finally this is from the wall street
journal a billionaire who recently
rocketed to the international space
station said he's sending one of his
prized john michael basquiat paintings
to auction this spring for an estimated
70 million dollars
you can see the painting there the move
hints at the shifting whims of the
world's wealthy but also underscores the
continuing strength of the art market
overall so that's the painting right
there we'll take a look at that that's
70 million dollars
looks like something uh that a
four-year-old future serial killer would
make with finger paint
during preschool art class
i could have vomited on that thing
yesterday when i had my stomach bug and
you wouldn't be able to tell the
difference
it could already have vomit on it for
all we know there's always impossible to
tell
so there's always this debate about uh
whether something qualifies as art or
not
and sure i'll say that that's art
technically it's just really bad art and
i i don't mean subjectively right it's
not subjectively bad it's objectively
bad it is objectively bad it is
objectively not beautiful
and all art should be striving for
beauty which isn't to say that all art
should be uh you know should be cheerful
doesn't mean that art can't sometimes be
sad or dark or even grim or whatever
it can be all those things but it should
still have beauty and meaning
and this has neither of those things
so it's just bad
but someone's gonna spend 70 million
dollars on that money well spent
um
let's get to the comment section do you
know their name
all right somehow
mckenna is still in charge of
compiling these video submissions the
video comments you go to dailywire.com
uh slash sweet baby comments and and
leave your own
i've still i've still haven't
i've still entrusted her to do this
and i give him our second chance really
so let's let's let's see what we got
let's go to clip nine
hello again mr walsh it's me it's uncle
murray i got a bone to pick with your
buddy that last video that i sent you
that afterwards that you threw your
producer under the bus your caster to
the dogs is the kid's sake and how could
you do that to such a sweet
long-suffering woman who works
tirelessly for you day in and day out
you know she's just trying to share a
little joy and a couple of chuckles with
you like i'm trying to share that with
you and then what do you do you you
throw under the bus and you threaten the
livelihood you jeopardize the food on on
her plate on a plate you know don't
worry about me you know don't worry
about hurting my feelings i got thick
skin you know i could take care of i
died inside you know just a little bit
and so you know you and me you know that
that's another battle general but how
could you be such a bully to such a
sweet producer like that shame shame on
you you overbearing tyrant of a bully
you ain't heard the last of me my friend
for shame
uh
this is
this is sabotage i know what this is i
know what's happening here
there are those
i don't know i don't it's mckenna's in
on it i don't know who else is but it's
a conspiracy
there are obviously those in this
building who don't like the comment
section segment of this show
don't like the video comments and
they're trying everything they can
to sabotage the segment
and it might actually work because if
this continues i don't think we could do
the video comments anymore um all right
this is why you never give people second
chances this is why you never do it um
all right let's go i'll go to the
written comments johnny says matt i saw
your instagram post and would like to
inform you that your man card is revoked
forever no man can eat a cake pop and
remain a man shame on you okay i did um
so i'll ask you guys about this so on
sunday i was out with my family stop for
a coffee and while i'm getting a coffee
i ordered myself a cake pop
chocolate cake pop with sprinkles and i
did specifically say that i wanted that
i was very specific and my wife for some
reason thought this was hilarious and
she took a picture of me holding the
cake while you could see there
nobody has ever looked less happy while
eating a dessert than me in that picture
but only because she's my wife's
laughing at me and and shaming me
and then keeps laughing about how my my
man card is revoked
so is that
is that really how far we've fallen as a
society that a grown man can't even eat
a cake pop anymore is that the sort of
toxic masculinity that we've come to
simply accept this idea that a man
can't still be a man as he says out loud
to a person behind the counter i'd like
a cake pop with chocolate chocolate and
sprinkles please
and then the proceeds to eat said cake
pop
do i really lose my man card over that
am i banned for my own show
i'll leave it up to you the judge and
the jury to decide
um
let's see i j kelly says matt i'm an
avid viewer of your show from england
i'm a big fan and i agree wholeheartedly
with 99.9 of what you say
uh my burning question to you though is
this does a sweet baby gang extend to
the uk and other nations or are you
strictly a u.s outfit much love
the sweet baby gang is international of
course i'm not xenophobic um i wouldn't
exclude foreigners you're welcome to
join
you'll have to pay a 300 processing fee
of course undergo a background check
renounce your country of origin
and work for 12 years as an indentured
servant in america
to an american member of the gang but
other than that you're absolutely
welcome
we don't discriminate finally greg says
matt your your friday show was
disappointing i get that you're more the
culture war guy but you need to be able
to put that aside and focus on more
important things in the world sometimes
everyone's talking about the major
crisis in europe and you're ranting
about trans people again real war
greater than sign culture war
well you're right i did i did commit the
sin of talking about something other
than what everyone else is talking about
for some reason as a listener of the
show that annoys you which i don't quite
understand
just just from a sort of pure
entertainment perspective i don't
understand that
do you really want and need to hear me
say the same thing that you've already
heard a million people say already
why would you even want that
and if you do
i'm not sure why you're a fan of this
show to begin with given that i
frequently ignore the major headlines
and talk about other things
there have been major stories that have
been in the news for weeks of time and i
never even mention them that's what you
get on this show
and i do that because i believe other
things are still important even if the
corporate media says otherwise
you know with the corporate media it's
it's
one thing at a time one thing is of most
important the most important thing in
the world and then that is just tossed
to the side and then there here's
another thing that's the most important
thing in the world
and as soon as we move on to the next
thing it's like that other thing never
happened we never we never speak of it
again
and if you think that won't happen with
uh with the situation ukraine it will
because when you're in the midst of the
hysteria it's hard to imagine that like
by next week
nobody will be talking anymore but
that's that's the way it goes in this
country
now if this turns into a global world
war that might be different but um if
not then yeah that's the way it'll go
and i believe that um
you know i also disagree with you about
about real war quote unquote being more
important than the culture war now if
our own country was being physically
invaded by a foreign military i i would
probably agree that such an event would
be the most pressing concern for all of
us at that moment but it isn't right now
and hopefully it stays that way and so
i mean our country is being invaded just
not by a foreign military not an
official capacity
so the question is whether a war between
foreign countries is more important more
immediately relevant more pressing more
urgent more likely to impact your life
or hurt you or your children than the
state of our culture
i think the answer to that is no
doesn't make the war overseas
unimportant
but yes i believe that fighting for our
culture here at home is still more
important i do believe that
well tonight is joe biden's first
official state of the union address and
the one thing i guarantee you is that
you're not going to hear a lot of truth
that's the one thing you won't hear
that's because the
presidency is an unmitigated disaster
supply chain crisis energy crisis
debacle in afghanistan all self-induced
and now war in ukraine much of it if not
all of it due to joe biden's feckless
and embarrassing leadership of course
biden is never going to say any of that
but uh ben shapiro will what am i
talking about tonight exactly 15 minutes
following president biden's remarks
before a joint session of congress ben
will offer up his response we'll call it
the real state of the union ben is going
to tell you where we really are as a
country i promise you ben's real estate
union response will be free of focus
group testing and he'll be holding the
president accountable there will be no
hiding behind covet or blaming rogue
dictators put simply ben will destroy
joe biden's state of the union with
facts and logic so join me ben shapiro
jeremy jeremy boring michael knowles
andrew clavin tonight at 8 15 p.m
eastern 7 15 p.m central on the daily
wire youtube channel the real estate of
the union response with ben shapiro will
be airing as soon as biden's address
ends on the same channel so make sure to
tune in now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
well the left-wing blogs informed me
yesterday that john oliver had returned
to his hbo show to deliver another epic
smackdown this time destroying
demolishing eviscerating
anti-prostitution laws oliver is uh
quite sure that there is no good reason
for prostitution to be illegal he's even
more sure that it's
mostly just a bunch of repressed
puritanical bumpkins who still support
such laws now he begins his segment by
playing some kind of weird 1950s psa
about wet dreams
don't ask me why then he proceeds to
list a bunch of sex positions while the
audience cackles uproariously this is
just great comedy watch this
specifically tonight we're going to talk
about sex work and the concept is pretty
simple let's say you have sex any kind
uh missionary doggy cowgirl cowboy the
eagle the wheelbarrow the wild chinkatik
pony the jerry seinfeld the pick me up
that put me down mouth butt butt mouth
mouth mouth butt butt butt butt mouth
butt you know whatever but then that's
it you go home it's fine right
so you see there why oliver needs the
crutch of a live studio audience
because without the mindless drones
laughing that would have just been a
sex-crazed schizophrenic randomly
shouting a bunch of sexual terms into
the abyss
with the laughing it's still that but at
least the people in the room are
enjoying it i guess
but it sets the stage for what's to come
oliver proceeds to lay out his case for
decriminalizing prostitution everywhere
in the country he has 20 25 minutes to
present the argument in favor of
prostitution but waste most of it
talking about alleged instances of abuse
by the law enforcement officers tasked
with policing the practice so he
mentions for example a report claiming
that officers in sting operations
sometimes have sex with the prostitutes
before arresting them
now we can all agree that if that's
happening it's wrong and horrible and
exploitative
but it has nothing to do with whether
prostitution should be legal or illegal
there are plenty of cases of police
officers mistreating murder suspects
that doesn't mean murder should be legal
so before we talk about
how these laws are enforced and i
personally think they should be enforced
by first and foremost penalizing the
pimps and traffickers themselves before
we can do that we need to figure out if
the laws should exist at all
oliver doesn't really have a lot to say
about that subject even though it's
ostensibly the subject of his episode of
this episode of his show but let's
listen to his case for whatever it may
be worth
he starts things off by
drawing what actually is a valid
comparison and one that listeners of
this show have already heard many times
listen to this
very basically sex work is the exchange
of sex for money or goods and in the
united states a complicated patchwork of
local state and federal laws makes that
act illegal everywhere except for a few
counties in nevada and if you think it
were hold on john didn't donald
sutherland and julie christie have sex
for real in don't look now and also get
paid at least scale wouldn't that be
illegal the answer is one yes i also
believe that rumor great reference and
two that is actually legal because of
the presence of the camera making it an
art film otherwise known as porn and
thus legally covered as part of free
speech so basically consensual sex for
money on camera is legal porn and
consensual sex for money off camera is
illegal sex work makes sense right wrong
well exactly
everything about the way we regulate sex
work in this country is confusing and
counterproductive
oh where have i heard that before
i mean you're right john that is in fact
a point that i have made many times and
people on your side of the ideological
divide have mocked me relentlessly for
it i guess i need to say with a british
accent for it to be credible
um pornography is prostitution on film
it fits the definition in every sense of
the word it makes no sense for
prostitution to only be legal when
there's a camera filming it
in fact if you could only outlaw one
form
the filmed or unfilmed variety it would
make more sense to outlaw the former
because it has more participants
either way there's no denying the
contradiction in the way that our laws
treat prostitution as opposed to how
they treat pornography
my answer to that contradiction is to
make all of it illegal
his answer is to make it all legal and
um let's let's find out why
but a human history's worth of laws
hasn't changed the fact that one sex
work has always been part of society
appealing to every interest in every
kind of clientele and two sex workers
are not a monolith people from a variety
of backgrounds do it for a variety of
reasons and the fact is our current
system of criminalizing the trade and
driving everyone underground is actually
only making life harder for the most
vulnerable involved and given that sex
workers are and this is true people with
thoughts about their own situation we
thought tonight we'd actually listen to
so here john offers two incredible
insights
one he points out that prostitution has
always been around
and two he observes that uh some of the
people doing this illegal thing would
prefer if it were not illegal
now both of these points may seem rather
obvious and irrelevant but remember that
he dropped an f word in there which
automatically makes his point both
powerful and clever and funny
yes we know that there have been
prostitutes for as long as there's been
human civilization that's why the old
cliche about the world's oldest
profession
but we've also had murder and rape and
child abuse and every other bad human
activity for as long as we've had humans
the fact that people have been doing
something for a long time and will
always do it doesn't automatically mean
that there should be no laws against it
if it did then there shouldn't be laws
against anything because the only things
we need laws against are precisely those
things that human beings tend to do
if nobody did it we wouldn't need to
outline it
as for the point that anti-prostitution
laws ignore the perspective of
prostitutes that wouldn't be relevant if
it were true
because again
pointing out that the people doing the
illegal thing
don't like that it's illegal is not
really relevant but it's also not true
at all
because some of the most vocal
anti-prostitution voices in the country
are people who've been rescued from that
life
prostitution is bad it harms people it
harms everybody involved in one way or
another
there's a reason why prostitutes just
like people in the porn industry have
astronomically high rates of substance
abuse
suicide
any law that could potentially prevent
people from getting involved in this
activity or deter them from it
or at least any law that fails to
condone it
is good for the prostitutes or potential
prostitutes themselves even if they
don't always have the self-awareness and
foresight to see it that way
you know it's it's pretty common for
people who are stuck in a
self-destructive cycle to defend their
self-destructive activity and to get
very angry at anybody who tries to stop
them from doing the self-destructive
thing
but that doesn't really mean anything in
terms of what the law should be
now we'll return to that point in just a
moment but first we'll continue
listening to oliver's argument such as
it is
so far he hasn't really presented any
reason to decriminalize it perhaps he
finally gets to that point here
this story is going to be about the fact
that sex work is inarguably labor it is
a job and people do it for the same
reasons that people do any job as this
advocate explains
sex work is inherently work it's how
people
feed their families is how people put
clothes on their backs it's you know how
people survive i mean i've been a sex
worker i've been a lawyer i've served
sandwiches at somewhat at subway i
folded clothes at abercrombie all those
are work right it's all work
uh okay
what's your point
yes those are all things you did for
money you folded clothes at abercrombie
you were a prostitute
uh you were a lawyer which would some
would argue is more of a lateral move
all of that is work if by work you
simply mean a task performed for
financial compensation but what does
that prove
are you saying that anything done for
money is automatically good or should
automatically be legal
that's quite an interesting take from
the same people who also tend to be
critics of capitalism
what about child pornographers what
about hired assassins
what about bernie madoff running a ponzi
scheme all of that is work done for
money
if you don't think that all of it should
be legal then you're saying that there
are certain types of jobs
certain types of work that nobody should
be legally allowed to do in a civilized
society even if they use it to feed
their families
the question is whether prostitution
ought to be in that category or not
and that is a question you still have
not really answered and never do but
we'll keep listening
to those who are still uncomfortable
here out of a concern that there are
people who feel economically forced into
sex work i totally agree with you that
is a huge problem but the fact is our
current laws are not addressing that if
you want to do that that's a much bigger
conversation to have because
fundamentally the only way to make sure
that people have a choice in the way
they earn money is to make housing
affordable healthcare accessible and to
not burden marginalized people with
criminal records that lead to a cycle of
joblessness homelessness and desperation
but until such time as we have that
conversation and it does not seem like
something enough people are itching to
have right now we need to stop pursuing
policies that harass in danger and
occasionally refrigerate sex workers and
instead start listening to what they
actually want because unfortunately if
we don't do that we're just going to
carry on looking like a bunch of
clowns
well speak for yourself john um now he
once again returns to the point that
people who are currently prostitutes do
not want prostitution to be a crime
again i must remind him that most of the
people currently engage in all types of
illegal illegal activity probably would
prefer if the activity was not illegal
it doesn't really help enlighten the
issue at all nor does it do anything to
negate the real reason why prostitution
is illegal almost everywhere and should
remain so
and that is this
prostitution
is human trafficking by definition
it is the human body sold as a good an
object
that's also what distinguishes
prostitution from legitimate forms of
work with legitimate labor you are
providing a good or service in exchange
for money in prostitution you are the
good you are the service
this is also how you differentiate you
know zip recruiter from a slave auction
you're not buying the slaves labor
really you're buying him
the slave himself is the commodity and
so is the prostitute
the prostitute gives herself up to be
used and discarded it is inherently
dehumanizing degrading violent
despair inducing
oliver mentions how poor and vulnerable
people tend to be the ones on street
corners offering to perform oral sex on
strangers which is true but he never
stops to ask himself why
putting the law aside why is it almost
always poor and desperate people who end
up going down this dark road
there are exceptions of course and the
internet version of prostitution
provides many of those exceptions but
the vast majority of the hookers on
street corners are poor desperate
drug-addicted girls
that's not going to change by making it
legal
it's not like if you legalize it
suddenly a bunch of middle-class
financially stable women are going to
flock to the corner hoping to get their
turn humping a random dude in a car
parked by a dumpster
this is something that only people in
dire straits do because it is debasing
humiliating dirty and shameful
and dangerous
that's not an argument for making it
legal and if you think it is i have to
question not only your common sense but
your basic moral judgment as well
now the prostitute apologist will say
that the prostitutes are acting
consensually but we know that's not true
in a great number of cases many of these
girls are physically forced and coerced
into it and again you're not going to
alleviate those cases by making the
practice legal
pornography is legal and that certainly
hasn't done anything to put a dent in
the child porn business
the effect has gone entirely the other
way
as for prostitutes many did not choose
that life
that's reason enough to keep it illegal
but even the ones who appear to have
chosen it didn't really choose it people
who think they have choices don't become
prostitutes
you'd think this would be obvious to the
left especially as they're the ones who
say that a boss having sex with a
subordinate is automatically a race a
rapist because because the power
dynamics make consent impossible right
that was the me too logic
now if they can apply that principle to
the workplace
where it should not actually be applied
most of the time how can they exempt
prostitution
but however you look at the consent
question the fact remains the
prostitution is human trafficking it is
the buying and selling of human beings
it is exploitation of the most degrading
and dehumanizing kind
whether everybody agrees to the
arrangement or nobody does or some
people do but others don't or whatever
other combination
it still should not be legal
and john oliver is still today certainly
canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pavel
voldowski the show is edited by robbie
dantzler our audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is done by
cherokee heart and our production
coordinator is mckenna waters matt wall
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2022
as putin threatens nuclear winter
democrats focus on outlawing lynchings
from a century ago ukraine attempts to
join the eu and one russia expert says
we are already in world war iii check it
out on the michael knowles show